ce que propose le gouvernement ce que
lisent de l'intérieur et le ministre des
comptes publics gérald darmanin avons
proposé demain aux élus un système
contractuel c'est à dire pour 300 moi on
va 10320 françois barois entendu le
chiffre de 350 morts et 150
collectivités
c'est à dire toutes les régions tous les
départements les gros agglo et quelques
grandes villes un système où en 2019 en
2018 pardon il n'y a pas de baisse des
concours et à partir de 1019 on commence
à compter les blues comme à la fin de la
foire et on regarde sur les bons élèves
les mauvais élèves etc
mais pour que nous acceptions cela nous
les départements faut-il encore que on
sache qu'il ya dans ces contrats et par
exemple est ce que au moment de signer
ces contrats avec notre préfet de région
préfet du département
nous aurons réglé le gouvernement
d'autres dossiers parmi les plus
difficiles avec celui des mineurs
accompagnés non accompagnés se dire du
financement du rsa du rsa pas seulement
à bien et ça ne l'a pas pour les
personnes âgées qui dans certains
départements et encore plus coûteux que
le rsa et l'appréciation qu'en passant
du handicap car si j'allais signer
demain un contre avec mon préfet assez
parfait pour l'année 2019 mais qu'en
même temps l'état continue de ne pas
nous payer ce qu'il nous doit sur le
financement des solidarités sociales
vous signez pas vraiment quoi je ne
signerai pas aimer mais s'il n'y est pas
qu est ce que les collègues présents
département ne signerons pas nous allons
le dire demain très officiellement au
gouvernement
non pas que nous trouvions la méthode la
contractualisation mauvaise mais parce
que nous voulons savoir quel est le
contenu du contrat et quelles seront la
réalité nos dépenses de fonctionnement
en 2018 si l'histoire des mineurs
étrangers dans la compagnie qui va
coûter au bloc départementale 1 milliard
d'euros cette année
si la sphère du rsa et du de l'apa ne
sont pas commencés à être arrivé si la
négociation réelle et concrète n'a pas
commencé on va pas signer des contrats
dont on ne connaît pas les les clauses
et le contenu